الاعلى نحاكم ومدينه سيفاستيفال الروسيه
ميخائيل للراس فوجاز ان دفاعات الجويه
اسقطت مسيرتين كانتاتها جمال المدينه وقال
الراسبوجاز على قناته في تلجرام من قوات
الدفاع جوي تعمل الان وان هناك هجوما
بطائرات دون طيار وفقا للمعلومات الاوليه
مؤكدا ان جميع القوات والخدمات في حاله
تاهب وان اي من المنشات المدنيه لم تصب
من جانبه قال الجيش الاوكراني من
الانفجارات مساء اليوم في مدينتي في
مدينتي في شبه جزيره القرم دون اي يقدمه
مزيدا من التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
معنى الالم منك ولا عايز مراسله جزيره
تامر
المسيرتين ماذا بشان الروايه الروسيه
المدينه
لا توجد في الحقيقه تفاصيل كثيره عن هذين
الهجومين لكن قبل ذلك كانت وسائل الاعلام
في شبه جزيره القرم قد تحدثت عن سماع دوي
ثلاثه انفجارات في مناطق مختلفه ومنها ما
يبعد طبعا عن مدينه اسطنبول الحديث هنا عن
سوريا وايضا عن بلاك لافا هاتين من
المدينتين تبعودان تقريبا عن مدينه
اسطنبول بنحو 70 كم لكن همم حاكم مدينه
اسطنبول قال بان الدفاعات الجويه تصدت
لهذا الهجوم الجوي طبعا دعا المواطنين الى
الحفاظ على الهدوء وقال بان كل الامكانيات
الان جاهزه من اجل حمايه شبه جزيره القرم
لكن هذا همم الهجوم ليس هو الاول طبعا
هناك هجمات اصبحت في الحقيقه ايمان تتكرر
تقريبا بشكل شبه اسبوعي الاسبوع الماضي
فقط همم تحدثت سلطات القرم عن احباط هجمات
في شبه الجزيره قبل ذلك وفي بدايه الشهر
ايضا كان هناك المحاوله للهجوم على محطه
لنقل الطاقه الكهربائيه في شبه جزيره
القرم والسلطات تاكدت على انها تصدت لي
مسيرات اوكرانيه فوق السماء المنطقه وايضا
قبل ذلك وتحديدا النهايه الشهر الماضي
كانت المنطقه قد تعرضت لهجوم مسيرات
اوكرانيه همم كانت تستهدف على ما يبدو همم
قطاعات بحريه في ميناء
هو القاعده الرئيسيه لاسطول البحر الاسود
الذي يشارك بشكل في هذه العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وهذا طبعا يحيدونا على هجمات اخرى سابقه
كانت قد عرضت لها همم يعني همم
قواعد عسكريه روسيه همم محطات لنقل الطاقه
الكهربائيه
ومدينه سيفاسلوب وتحديدا ااه مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود في هذه المدينه الصيف همم
الماضي لكن ال- يعني الاجانب الروسي
السلطات الروسيه في شبه جزيره القرم الا
طالما اكدت على ان سماء شبه الجزيره محميه
بشكل جيد كما تقول طبعا بالدفاعات الجويه
وايضا هناك يقضى من قبل السلطات وهذا طبعا
ايضا يحيينا الى تصريحات اللي همم اكشن
شبه جزيره القرن المعين طبعا من قبل روسيا
الاسبوع الماضي الذي تحدث عن اجراءات
اضافيه لضمان امن همم المنطقه همم خاصه
مباراه التي شهدتها منطقه خرسون همم
الاسبوع الماضي بانسحاب القوات الروسيه
وايضا بانتقال خطا الدفاع الاول للجيش
الروسي الى الضفه اليسرى من نهر نيبر في
مقاطعه خرسون
الان حيث هو انت تامر لكن ماذا بالنسبه
للروايه الاوكرانيه فيما يتعلق هاتين
المسيرتين امم التي يقول حاكم بان دفاعات
الجويه يتصدت لها
نعم ايمان بالفعل السلطات الاوكرانيه
تحديدا الجيش الاوكراني قياده عمليات
الجنوب الاوكرانيه تتحدث بشكل مقتضب عن ما
يجري حاليا في شبه جزيره القرم لكن وانا
انتظر هذا الهواء جددت
القوات الاوكرانيه تاكيدها بان الانفجارات
مازالت متواصله وهنالك اكثر من انفجار على
ما يبدو وفقا للروايه الاوكرانيه في شبه
جزيره القرم وتقول بان هذه الانفجارات
تحديدا
فيفا ستوبل وهذه المدينه المهمه
الاستراتيجيه التي يوجد فيها كما اشاره
زميل امين همم قياده الاسطول البحر الاسود
التابعه القوات الروسيه والتي تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه بانها تنفذ ضربتها الجويه على
عدد من المدن الاوكرانيه منذ بدايه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا حتى هذه اللحظه لا
مزيد من التفاصيل باستثناء هذا التصريح
المقتدر الصادر عن الجيش الاوكراني لكن
كما قال امين ايضا
شبه جزيره القرم تنظر اليها القوات
الاوكرانيه على انها يعني وجهها واضحه
لضرب مناطق اوكرانيه عده طيله الفتره
الماضيه وهي تقول بانها تسعى الى ااا
تكثيف هجماتها ايضا على شبه جزيره القرم
ولافت في الحقيقه ايمان ان هذه هذا الحدث
الكبير والمهم الذي وقع للتو قبل القليل
ياتي بعد ساعات فقط من اعلان القوات
الاوكرانيه بانها رصد التحركات همم القوات
الروسيه همم امدادات جديده تاتي من شبه
جزيره القرم الى الضفه اليسرى من نهر
دنيبر التي تتواجد فيها القوات الروسيه
هذه القوات التي غادرت وان سحبت من مدينه
خيرسون هذه المدينه التي اصبحت اليوم بشكل
كامل مع القوات الاوكرانيه تقول السلطات
بانها رصد التحركات بالفعل من القوات
الروسيه قادمه من شبه جزيره القرم الى تلك
الضفه الضفه دينيبر وانها تحاول هذه
القوات الروسيه تكثيف هجماتها على خير سون
من تلك الجهه والحديث عن عشرات الانفجارات
التي وقعت اليوم في مناطق عديده من خيرسون
تقول السلطات بان هنالك قتلى وجرحى في
صفوف المدنيين وتقول ايضا بانها تكثف من
قصفها للقوات الروسيه المتواجده على نهر
دنابر على الضفه الاخرى كما تشير القوات
الاوكرانيا